the lockdown in indian-administered
Kashmir amounts to an abuse of power
that's the ruling from India's Supreme
Court five months since the government
removed the territory's autonomy
restricted people's movements and
blocked the internet those who
challenged the shutdown say it's a
significant verdict the stand taken by
the state was that these are national
security issues please leave it to the
state
the court has trucked that down and said
no this will be subject to judicial
review the Indian government argued it
needed to block the internet to stop
what it called separatists and terror
groups from communicating with each
other but the court found the government
had breached telecom rules and gave
authorities in the territory a week to
review the restrictions a student in
Surrey Nagar the capital of
indian-administered Kashmir has welcomed
the court's judgment if Indian
government is trying to suppress this or
they are not trying to what you can say
however should be listened by the other
personalities of the world and that's
why they are putting ads all these curbs
on the internet other things here for
over five months the journalists in the
valley have been given access to just a
few computers enabled with the internet
it's always difficult for a journalist
but when you are depriving him after
like the basic tool which is internet
then you are then it's it's a deliberate
attempt to make his work more difficult
several restrictions including on phone
connections have already been lifted now
many people are waiting for the internet
to be restored legal experts say the top
court's verdict will also affect other
areas where the internet has been shut
down and freedom of assembly limited
after indian-administered Kashmir the
Indian government deployed the same
measures in Assam and a neutralization
during protests against the
controversial citizenship Amendment Act
art ahora al Jazeera
New Delhi thousands of protesters have
marched in the southern Indian city of
Hyderabad against the new citizenship
law the legislation ratified last one
the way for citizenship for minorities
from three neighboring countries but
excludes Muslims Hyderabad has a sizable
population and the rally was organized
by politicians from the community who
are opposed to the policies of Prime
Minister Narendra Modi now Modi is
expected to travel to the eastern city
of Kolkata on Saturday where marchers
have already begun students plan to
block major roads from the airport in
protest against this citizenship
amendment act as well as government
proposals to increase university fees
Sohail Raman is in Kolkata with the
protesters tens of thousands of people
have gathered here very close to the
Mahatma Gandhi monument in Calcutta in
West Bengal to show their discontent
with the citizenship Amendment Act I
don't think I've ever seen crowds like
this
other than at a general election
campaign and besides civil society in
and across community representation
regarding rebellious religions what you
have a civil society leaders and
religious leaders who are making their
speeches to the assembled crowd they
want the government to understand that
the citizenship Amendment Act is illegal
unconstitutional and doesn't fit in with
the secular nature of India that's the
message they want to get across to
Narendra Modi he arrives here on
Saturday and they want to make sure that
their voice their placards very intent
is heard not just in New Delhi but
across the country they are joining
hundreds and thousands of other people
across India that are continuing their
demonstrations are continuing their
protest and they heard that Narendra
Modi will get to see and understand
exactly the strength of feeling here
certainly in West Bengal a state that he
has no control over and that the
incumbent government hopes then he will
of course understand that he's not
welcome